thank you to
Taylor Swift for doing a savior for me
and that is
writing a song called
you're on your own kid
Stevie Nicks thanking Taylor Swift amid
her grief
[Music]
seven months after the death of her
Fleetwood Mac bandmate Christine McVee
who died last November well I think his
time isn't it I mean you know the old
adage Time Heals which is I mean it's
obviously a cliche for a reason you know
that is the sadness of
as long as Chris was even on the other
side of the world we didn't have to talk
on the phone that's the iconic singer on
Monday in Atlanta opening up to the
crowd about their special bond across
nearly 50 years of friendship it was
like and then we'd go back to Fleetwood
Mac and we'd walk in and it would be
like a little sister how are you and it
was like no
you know no one
never a minute had passed no never an
argument in our entire 47 years thank
you to
Taylor Swift
that is writing a song called
you're on your own kid
that song it's All tastes 2022 album
midnights
[Music]
just to learn that my dreams
you're on your own kid you always happen
music has helped me so much in just
getting through life uh and that's one
of the things I'm very thankful to have
discovered songwriting
[Music]
okay
you can face this when it was the two of
us the two of us were on our own kid
we always will and now I'm having to
learn to be on my own kid by myself when
Christine died following a brief illness
Stevie called her my best friend in the
whole world since the very first day of
1975. the year Stevie joined Fleetwood
Mac and launched the group into
worldwide success thanks in part to hits
like Rihanna
if you've never seen
35 years later Taylor and Stevie sang a
duet of the iconic song at the Grammy
Awards
[Music]
when you go through something this life
that I live where you write songs about
things even the things that don't work
out it it's kind of like a justification
system you're like you know what that
didn't work out but it was worth
something because it made me feel
something back at Stevie's concert the
song Chris gay fans these words of
wisdom so take care of yourselves be
well
who you are thank you
thank you I'm all grown up now I'm
fearless I'm to the point now in my life
where I'm going life is short Life's too
short so when great things come your way
don't walk away from them just embrace
it and have fun with it and do your best
[Music]